The Joe Rogan Experience so the village
that we were staying with the guys
informed me that now way up the river
30 miles or so there was an area that I
would love to have collected in
but I couldn't because it was controlled
by a group of Yana Mama that had shot at
everybody who'd ever gotten near there
and uh you know shot arrows and uh so I
was afraid to go up there to do any
collecting but then our group of
yodomamo informed me that these guys had
gone off on a raid to attack another
group and probably wouldn't be back for
a couple of months
so I got Brave
and went up into their area where I
didn't think they were going to be with
a young man in Venezuelan who worked for
me and we had just parked our Dugout
canoe on the bank and had gone out into
the woods to set nets for bats when we
hear a hundred or so maybe not a hundred
but a goodly number of
men coming down the trail and we
immediately thought oh my God we're
going to be absolutely dead Ducks if
they find us
and but I did know that they don't
usually go after their query they
usually wait in Ambush so we hid out in
the jungle until about two o'clock in
the morning and then tried turning our
lights really dim and sneaking along
without making any noise to get back to
our canoe and hoping they were asleep
and we'll never know whether they were
asleep or not because
we did get shoved off and got away
but the very next night we were stupid
enough to think we had gone far enough
away that they wouldn't find us and we
went back and tried to net again
and then we heard Jaguar noises
and I had a Yana mama and a my katitari
Indian working for me and they
immediately
started worrying me
that's that's that's not El Tigre uh
that's that's the the Indians that we're
trying to avoid and uh making Jaguar
noises right commit to communicate among
themselves oh wow
and fi but I insisted I thought that
these guys were just uh trying to get
out of work because I'd been working
them pretty hard and if they wanted to
go to bed early that night so I didn't
really take them very seriously and I
went off with my shotgun back then we
were collecting everything from Jaguars
to mice and
um so in in those days it was a big
Macho thing to shoot a Jaguar so I go
off with my shotgun to hunt the jaguar
and it kept moving too fast without
noise in between and I finally dawned on
me that hey this more like Indians than
Jaguars to me even I went back and my
guys were just ready to actually abandon
me and leave me they were so scared oh
no we didn't even take the Nets down we
got out of there as fast as we could
went back to camp and the next day we
came back to get our nets all the main
strands of the Nets had been stolen
proving that these were Indians that
were after address and we probably just
got out in time
that's the most danger you've ever been
in
I
I don't know I mean there was the time I
was crawling into a cave and on my belly
in a narrow passage and all of a sudden
found that there was a big Cobra coming
out and I had to lay perfectly still so
the Cobra didn't get upset while he was
going by so you had to lay perfectly
still where the Cobra slithered by you
yeah whoa
and there was a time the River Bandits
came after us
River Bandits where was that
was in Venezuela and the cost of Cary
canal
um
we
we've I've
we're getting into stories that probably
ought to be told at another time when
we're not distracting from bats but uh
now they're fun we could go back to bats
to put a long story shorter uh the cost
of carry Canal is the longest world's
longest natural canal and out in the
middle of it they're just no humans
around
and we were camped out there collecting
for the Smithsonian
but I carried a lot of small cash to do
business when I did come to where there
were villages
the small cash was hidden in false
bottoms of trunks uh the way I got the
cash we were funded through a military
Grant and anybody knows anything about
the military knows they've got every
restriction Under the Sun on their money
and accounting for it
I had
known that their rules weren't going to
work very well for collecting and so I
had gotten bids from playing Charter
companies
to fly us out to this remote Savannah
and it was they were going to encourage
a lot of money because it was risky to
the planes
and uh
so
I got
the military to send the money to the
Bank of America in caucus
and then this was time when you had
machine guns at the door of every Bank
and I mean it was a dangerous time in in
uh
Venezuela period Well we pretended to
change Christmas gifts
and that's how we got our money in the
small change and took it back to our
hotel then we put it in false bottoms of
trunks then we go out to the frontier
and after a while the word kind of gets
around that these guys can always pay
for something they must have some secret
supply of money
so one day we're out of this remote camp
and Mike Venezuelan helpers Indians uh
came running up saying oh you know in
Spanish kidato the the
the
Vandal not vandals but uh
the robbers are coming
and uh
they were coming up the river in a
little motorized Dugout and so that's
how my guys heard them in time to know
that they were coming and then they saw
them and realized who they were
and uh
so I had just a couple minutes it's kind
of interesting because I was reared to
be a conscientious objector
and uh you know didn't believe in in
fighting in war and uh
so here we are with the bandits coming
armed with shut it was kind of
interesting they had old Muzzleloader uh
guns that they actually used rocks in
rocks and black powder still to shoot
and but here they're coming and I'm
responsible for
eight or ten people their lives and am I
going to be a conscientious objector or
what am I going to do
and so I broke out all the guns we had
gave everybody one of the you know
everything from an M1 rifle to a couple
double barrel shotguns pistols and uh
got everybody positioned behind rocks
and logs and then as the bandits
approached I yelled down to them in
Spanish that we understood who they were
and if they touched that rock we're
going to kill them
and they kept coming
and so I finally had everybody show
themselves and their guns and yelled one
more time and the last time I yelled
they were within a meter of hitting the
bank and at that point we'd have had to
kill them but they finally at the last
minute when they saw their outgunned and
we had the upper hand they backed up and
went off
that ought to be hair raising it was
but I learned a lot about my
conscientious objector are you ready to
abandon it well I mean what are you
going to do you're going to let good
people die just because you don't
believe in firing a gun in a human yeah
that's a good point right yeah very
important lesson to learn right yeah it
was an important one for me
uh but boy you've had some pretty
amazing experiences just studying bats
around the world it's been a wild life I
bet huh well I've never chosen to get
myself into Big Adventures but yeah I
just chose you one of my all-time
favorite things to do is to go places
where almost nobody's ever been like
when I went out to see the uh shamatory
Indians
I had to hike 46 miles across country
from the last yanamama Village to get
out there and see them and uh
I just went out there I mean I knew it
was dangerous uh how dangerous I didn't
know but uh
I just was driven by curiosity here's a
once in a lifetime opportunity to see a
group of people that have only seen two
other Outsiders in their whole existence
and it was just so much fun going out
there and seeing experiencing that kind
of thing
but I certainly got into the high
adventure while I was out there
yeah that sounds amazing so you gotta
hike how long did it take you to hike 46
miles to get to them
well we did it in a day and a half I had
a 40 some pound pack uh
we went extra fast because
I did not know when we started on the
trip that the reason them see these two
shamatory came out to uh
visit our our yanamamo group because
they were looking for allies in the
battle
they're expecting to be raided by
another tribe whoa and I didn't know
this is why they were there but when I
asked through my interpreters
and and let me point this out too when
you watch a movie and they're speaking
pigeon English
you know there's no such thing as a
place where people are really Aboriginal
and you're speaking in English to them
uh everything I said on that whole trip
out there had to be translated by me
from English to Spanish and then from
Spanish to microtori from Michael Atari
to Yana mom one from Yana Mama to
shamitari oh my God you can imagine
there are a few miscommunications
[Laughter]
so what year was this this was happening
this was 1967. okay so clearly there's
no cell phones no other ways of
communicating right wow so we did not
know that these guys were expecting an
attack until we had already left with
them to go out to their Village oh boy
and what we eventually found was that
the reason they welcomed us so strongly
was that they thought we'd bring our
bang sticks with us needing guns and be
good in the battle oh boy
and so
by the time we got there well we found
out that we had to camp out along the
trail the first night and we we found
out that
um
they were expecting attack
my two guys I had to have a Yana mom on
a my cadetari for the translations to go
and uh incidentally they knew enough
that they wouldn't go it I I had a
terrible time getting them to go when I
finally convinced him I had to pay him a
month's wages for every day they went
out there with me
[Laughter]
so that first night we set up camp by a
beautiful stream in the jungle
and um then then my guys got really
suspicious when our Two shamitari Hosts
went off by themselves quite a ways away
in in a hidden place in the jungle to
put up little shelters for their night
and so they got suspicious went and
checked and found that they're worried
about being attacked and they were
leaving us out on the trail to be the
bait
and uh so but the next day we we arrived
out there
in my microt Atari guide had uh
experienced he'd been in a yonamama
village during an attack once and so he
since we knew they were thinking of
being attacked anytime he instructed me
what to do if we were attacked and he
said you know right off you know play
dead
and we were thinking that the attack
might come at night
and sure enough the very first night
were there
I mean talk about scary experiences long
before we thought we were being attacked
there were people that had malaria and
there were guys getting really high on
drugs to chase the hakura the Devils out
and uh they were going around the Devils
out right they mean they believed that
everything was attributable to Spirits
you mean malaria yeah uh there were good
spirits and bad spirits they hadn't
evolved to think of God one God and one
devil there are just a lot of spirits
with good ones and bad ones
and they were trying to chase the bad
ones out of the village by getting high
on dope and then shooting those Cherry
tipped arrows at the hallucinated images
so what drugs are they getting high on
Eben it's a powder that they I'm trying
to think what they make it from a Vine I
believe and what is the Psychedelic
substance they blow it up their noses oh
okay if you go to my if you go to my
website there's a place on the website
where you can
I'm trying to remember we can tell you
later exactly how to get to it but I've
got a place on my website where you can
actually see that trip me out there with
I had a movie camera with me you can see
him blowing the dope up their nose and
we I've got it on film right up until
the guy tried to attack and kill me